nadège on vous avez vu tout à l'heure
avec beaucoup de manifestants autour de
vous qu'en est il maintenant est ce que
cette manifestation est toujours aussi
suivi quelle est l'ambiance
bah oui écouter grégory ils sont
plusieurs milliers de manifestants avoir
répondu présent aujourd'hui à cet appel
à la grève à cet appel à la
manifestation
des enseignants alors ce qui les
réclament ces manifestants c'est un plan
d'urgence pour l'éducation trois
semaines seulement après la rentrée
scolaire il estime que les annonces
réalisées par jean michel blanquer à la
fin du mois d'août dernier biens sont
loin d'être suffisantes le ministre de
l'éducation nationale avait par exemple
annoncé une augmentation de salaire qui
se situe entre 39 et à 57 euros pour
tous les enseignants à partir de 2022 et
c'est bien trop peu c'est rien en
comparaison avec ce que propose la maire
de paris anne hidalgo qui elle de son
côté promet si elle est élue présidente
de la république en 2022 vient de
doubler le salaire des enseignants alors
certains manifestants présents ici sont
estiment qu'ils sont loin d'être dupe et
qu'il s'agit est bien de la part de la
mère de paris de d'un but purement
électoralistes puisque elle compte sur
le soutien des enseignants pour se faire
élire je vous propose justement
d'écouter quelques manifestants que l'on
a pu interroger tout à l'heure il faut
des moyens pour dédoubler les effectifs
il faut des programmes qu'ils soient
aménagés
tenir compte des retards d'apprentissage
après deux ans les élèves ont eu moins
d'exposition au savoir il faut les
accompagner dans les classes pour faire
en sorte qu'on puisse les aider à
réussir en tout cas il faut faire que
les enseignants puissent faire leur
travail avec des salaires décents ils
n'auraient crise de recrutement qui fait
qu'on n'arrive pas à voir de jeunes
profs dans nos métiers il ya donc
nécessité de s'intéresser à leurs
conditions de travail alors salaires et
surtout aux moyens pour faire que nos
jeunes puissent réussir à l'école
publique moi je suis dans l'académie de
créteil et dans l'académie de créteil on
a accueilli 3000 élèves en plus sans
aucun poste en plus donc en fait du coup
mathématiquement ça fait augmenter nos
effectifs dans les dents les classes
c'est pas le tout de vouloir faire des
choses avec nos élèves il faut en avoir
les moyens et quand on a trop d'élèves
pas assez de moyens pour les aider en
fait c'est frustrant essayez de dire à
la population française que le projet
éducatif
qui est proposé en france ne correspond
pas du tout notre idée de l'école quand
même imaginer qu'il ya énormément de
gens qui démissionne quand ils
commencent ce métier parce que c'est
extrêmement difficile ce n'est pas
reconnue et que on croule sous les
tâches administratives mais nous en tant
qu'enseignants et encore plus quand on
est directeur et outre une
revalorisation salariale ce que
réclament les manifestants présents ici
c est de meilleures conditions de
travail c'est aussi des créations de
postes d'enseignants de cp2 psychologue
de surveillant leur faut savoir que
depuis le quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
à 7400 90 postes ont été supprimés au
sein de l'éducation nationale est ce qu
ils réclament également ces manifestants
et bien c'est l'abrogation des réformes
blanc caire alors que le budget de
l'éducation nationale et étudié en ce
moment même à l'assemblée nationale un
budget pour 2022 en hausse d'un milliard
600 millions d'euros qui doit notamment
financer cette augmentation promise par
jean michel blanquer pour les
enseignants au moins de douze derniers
merci pour toutes cette analyse un adage
abderrazak en direct à du 6e
arrondissement de paris merci également
à massy ce mardi ross qui vous
accompagnent derrière la caméra